so we've got Donald Trump thinking about
firing Attorney General Jeff Sessions
clearly wants him to resign we also have
the country's top diplomat Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson thinking about
resigning himself why is Rex Tillerson
thinking about resignation because he
feels that Donald Trump has been
unprofessional in his treatment of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions two
different sources familiar with tiller
ins conversations with friends told CNN
over the weekend that Tillerson is so
frustrated with President Donald Trump
and the entire administration that we
may soon experience what is being called
wrecks it a possible resignation by Rex
Tillerson and once again I had the same
instinct with the spy sir scaramouche II
thing it's kind of hard to believe that
this is really what's making Rex
Tillerson all of a sudden consider
resignation Tillerson has had a pretty
tough week turns out he violated US
sanctions against Russia and he was
working as the CEO of Exxon Mobil yet
another Russia connected member of
trumps cabinet it's generally not going
great for Rex Tillerson but it seems to
me like the rats are looking for any
reason to jump ship at this point and
maybe it has more to do with the fact
that Tillerson has taken a backseat to
Jared Kushner when it comes to a lot of
policies look when Trump decided to
label Qatar as a harbor of terrorism I
was mostly Kushner's yeah it wasn't
actually Tillerson surprised about it
and suspected that this all came from
Kushner to begin with he wasn't in on it
and when you send a diplomat to go be
the liaison to Canada to Mexico to China
Trump's picking Kushner over him and I
think Tillerson looks at Kushner as you
know this guy who's half my age doesn't
have as distinguished of a career as I
do
I left a lucrative career at ExxonMobil
for this he is looking to bail and if he
can blame it on Jeff Sessions and taking
taking heat from Trump by all means
so we're six months in we've had
national security adviser Michael Quinn
forced to resign over lives related to
foreign contacts including conversations
with Russia from firing US Attorney
Preet Bharara when he was investigating
some very serious things that were
getting closer and closer to Donald
Trump we've had White House press
secretary Sean Spicer resign supposedly
because of the hiring of another White
House director level
staffer now Trump is considering firing
or at least pushing towards resignation
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and we've
got a Secretary of State considering
resignation and Trump fired Sally Yates
the former acting Attorney General sort
of carried over from the Obama
administration it's six months in do you
know how we have those death pools for
celebrities where people can bet on who
the next person to desirable we do and I
think I would have cashed out big-league
when it comes to Sean Spicer now I put
the the people most likely to quit or be
fired as probably Jeff Sessions than Rex
Tillerson then maybe Reince Priebus
laughter this is the one that comes to
me and it's weird because you don't hear
that much about him but when you've got
a White House in constant disarray you
do start looking at the chief of staff
who is presumably I mean in a normal
administration would sort of be involved
in staffing although it's kind of hard
to know whether Reince Priebus is
actually involved in that prepare
yourselves for Secretary of State
Ted Nugent folks or maybe it would be
Alex Jones is going to finally figure
out why the frogs are all turning gay
everybody here is looking for a reason
out right I mean they're looking for
some credible reason to say that was the
straw that broke the broke the camel's
back and I'm now leaving and the if
we're looking for some silver lining it
looks like Trump is finally draining the
swamp I mean we had Michael Michael
Flynn leave
maybe Attorney General Jeff Sessions
will be out Rex Tillerson might be on
his way out he filled it up first Pat
but now we're finally starting to see
that swamped right right but then you
got to replace these people and for many
of them it's going to be hard for them
to go through the Senate confirmation
process yeah and the timing of the
sessions thing real quick the timing of
the sessions thing could be such that
Trump might imagine he could do a recess
appointment during August and he could
put someone in his attorney general
without going through the confirmation
process but there's a system now to
prevent that I forget there's a there's
a Latin name for the term okay but
basically any one senator can sort of on
paper put them in session and I know I'm
not doing a great job of explaining it
and there's there's a particular term
that explains what this is and it would
prevent what is called as a recess
appointment that would circumvent
conformation so if trumpets thinking
that and that would require him to have
some knowledge and understanding of you
know senatorial procedure which is hard
to believe he has even if he's thinking
of that it's not necessarily going to
work that's it for the bonus show we had
a regular politics on the bonus show
today because our regular show was a
full hour in-depth interview with host
of the Reuben report gave Reuben thanks
to all of our new members and we'll be
back to the sort of normal David Pakman
show tomorrow I'm thrilled to tell you
that today's episode of the show is made
possible in part by tag a dab the
hosting specialists offering dedicated
virtual private and cloud server
solutions as well as custom server
solutions for whatever business or
project you have taga dabs web hosting
services support a very wide range of
customers and businesses that includes
bloggers tech startups financial traders
gamers web developers it's a very very
long list they've got a user-friendly
interface they have absolutely fantastic
technical support over 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
you can get a twenty British Pound
discount off of a cloud server account
with taga Deb but you've got to know how
to access that and the way you access it
is by going to sign up CagA Deb comm /t
DPS and using the coupon code TDPS
20 this is a great way to get great
hosting for your project business or
service and support the David Pakman
show and support our advertisers that
signup tag adapt calm slashed edps
that's ta ga da B and then the discount
code is TDPS
20